et oui l'objectif c'est d'obliger les
promoteurs à construire des bâtiments
plus vert bonjour eric b d'agde bonjour
david jacquot être l'installer vous dis
actionnaire de nexity ce qu'on appelle
la r eu 20/20 cette nouvelle norme
environnementale qui s'applique depuis
le 1er janvier
l'ambition a bien compris en creux c'est
de faire chuter les émissions de co2 des
bâtiments rappelle les bâtiments c'est
un quart des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre en france on se dit mais les
logements neufs actuelle il n'était pas
assez suffisant d'un point de vue
énergétique pas assez performant pour
aller fallait aller encore plus loin à
l'évidence il faut aller encore plus
loin puisqu'il ya une nouvelle
réglementation qui s'applique à partir
de cette année elle est très ambitieuse
il faudrait réduire nos et nos gaz à
effet de serre d'à peu près 30% d'ici
2030 2030 c'est demain être complètement
neutre en 2050
cette réglementation moi je pense que
pour nous elle est une chance en réalité
parce qu'elle nous donne un guide on
sait sur quoi on vous alors on doit
jouer à la fois sur les émissions
carbone et sur l'énergie et donc je
pense que pour tous les promoteurs au
fond c'est le but à atteindre et c'est
ce sur quoi nous sommes tous au fond
complètement concentré dans le moment
performant mais plus coûteux cette
nouvelle réglementation certains disent
que ça pourrait faire grimper certains
experts 10 5 % sur le coût de la
construction des appartements neufs
cette année et plus encore pour les
maisons ou confirme pas ce chiffre et
j'ai l'impression moi je ne sait pas
encore de combien parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'augmentation à vous savez sur
le logement il ya les produits qu'on met
finalement dans le logement il ya les
normes il ya effectivement là et revin
moi je pense que notre objectif à nous
mais vraiment c'est de rendre ce bas
carbone abordable c'est ça qu'on tente
de faire chez nexity et ça ça se fait
pas un oxymore c'est un an je ne pense
pas non mais je pense que c'est
volontariste en réalité donc ça suppose
de travailler évidemment sur sur les
matériaux on parle du bois porte de
montreuil nous on essaye le bois on
essaie la brique crue on essaye le
chanvre en échec la pierre on
on réutilise aussi au fonds d'aidé des
matériaux existants sur une partie de ce
qu'on a construit il y aura sur coup à
court terme après effectivement il y
aura des effets d'échelle et des
synergies mais à terme il ya un surcoût
qu'il y ait ce surcoût vers encore une
fois que je pense que ça dépend comment
on prend les choses je pense qu'il faut
vraiment revoir les modes constructifs
et de nouveau chez nexity on s'y prépare
depuis un moment il faut alléger il faut
simplifier il faut vraiment regarder ce
qui est absolument nécessaire émettre
plus de productivité aussi parce que je
vais de plus de productif entier et puis
acceptée vous l'avez vous même dit tout
à l'heure plus de rupture d'où par
exemple on travaille sur un bâtiment qui
existent et qui fonctionne je le dis ça
fonctionne en autriche à fonctionne en
suisse on appelle ça le bâtiment est
essentielle c'est vraiment comme son nom
l'indiqué c'est un bâtiment sans
chauffage etc l'un sans climatisation ou
son chantage de 100 pays bien sûr or
c'est un mélange au fond de mode
constructif très traditionnelle et mur
assez épais ouvrez circulation d'air
mais léa au meilleur de ce qu'on sait en
physique et en digital aujourd'hui ces
terres que grosso modo la température
intérieure du bâtiment se réguler en
fonction évidemment de la température
extérieure de la de l'isolation et donc
de l'inertie du bâtiment de la
circulation de l'air de la présence
d'humains dans le bâtiment enfin voilà
donc c'est vraiment ça que nous on
pousse aujourd'hui dont vous avez dit
rupture pays mais à court terme
j'insiste beaucoup disent que construire
vert sera plus chère avec l'idée que qui
payent l'addition à ce stock client paie
l'addition s'il ya son corps une fois
ces hausses de coûts et s'il est ce
qu'il en a le moyen est ce que le risque
justement contraire c'est d'avoir des
logements durables qu'ils soient
réservés à une élite le contraire de ce
que vous souhaitez ça je pense que c'est
vraiment c'est un risque c'est vraiment
au coeur je pense des tensions qui
existent dans nos entreprises
aujourd'hui nous vous savez nexity
militants ça c'était le combat
historique d'alain dinin pour le
logement abordable et donc effectivement
il faut que le logement vert ne soit pas
un logement réservé à une élite parce
que on a laissé les coudées river mais
si moi je pense que si on fait les
bâtiments tels qu'ils existent
aujourd'hui contente de les rendre plus
durable là effectivement les couvents
froidement augmenté il faut repartir sur
les modes constructifs après c'est vrai
que tout pousse aujourd'hui les prix des
mobilier neuf à la hausse on peut
revenir aux fondamentaux le déséquilibre
chronique endémique en france entre
l'offre et la demande de logements la
réglementation environnementale ça on
l'a évoqué les pénuries les flambées de
deux matériaux c'est sur une réalité
les prix du foncier ou six ans pour en
parler saison ouais on se dit voilà les
hausses de prix des logements cette
hausse elle est quasi certaine pendant
le futur faut pas trop se leurrer non
plus nous regardent aujourd'hui avec
beaucoup d'intérêt le débat qui assure
le pouvoir d'achat oui puisque c'est
extrêmement liés puisque les postes 2 et
le premier poste des dépenses des
français alors souvent on escamote le
débat parce qu'on dit bon c'est une
dépense obligatoire incompressibles moi
je veux bien qu'elle soit obligatoire
est ce qu'elle est vraiment
incompressibles je pense qu'aujourd'hui
il ya un vrai déséquilibre entre l'offre
et la demande nous on ne produit pas
hauteur de la demande qui nous est
adressé à la fois par les clients
particuliers et par les clients
institutionnels
donc il faut vraiment comme l'aurait dit
et comme l'a dit le rapport elle s'amène
réhabiliter l'acte de construire ce
qu'il faisait à part dont deux pays ce
qui veut dire retravailler la densité
dans la ville a donc des immeubles plus
haut 10 immeubles plus haut après ce que
les édiles est ce que les mères elles
acceptent mais il faut je pense je pense
que c'est un vrai débat social parce que
grosso modo vous le savez aujourd'hui on
va réduire l'artificialisation des
terres donc on aura évidemment parce
qu'au fond dans notre pays la ressource
naturelle qui est l'espace est en train
de devenir plus rare et donc
effectivement dans ce dans cette
ressource naturelle qui va être de plus
en plus limitées mais il va falloir
densifier donc a pas de fatalité à la
hausse des prix continue des logements
et jusqu'à ce que vous l'avez dit
vous-même si les la hausse des prix
continue et on va vraiment avoir un
monde à deux vitesses où il y aura
effectivement une partie de la
population qui pourra s'offrir
d un appartement en centre-ville bas
carbone et puis les autres qui auront
vraiment beaucoup plus de difficultés
donc là évidemment c'est un sujet de
société c'est l'intérêt d'ailleurs au
delà de la sujet de réglementation c'est
vraiment au fond quelle société on veut
pour demain donc pour l'ensemble du
secteur véronique dax est une c'est une
révolution c'est un big bang je le
disais parce que en gros un jeu je passe
tout contrôler mais béton briques acier
tous et à terme est condamné moi je
pense que j'ai un peu fort là je pense
que vous y allez un peu fort moi je
prends la terre oui je pense que de plus
en plus en fait on se dit qu'il faut
être efficace il ya des mélanges bois et
et tombe à carbonne qui sont vraiment
optimaux donc oui effectivement il y
aura de plus en plus de matériaux
biosourcés mais je pense que ça ne
signifie pas d'ambiance ressources et
c'est effectivement des des matériaux
qui sont expliquées qu'il garde le
carbone comme le comme le bois en
particulier donc bois mélangé avec
d'autres matériaux par exemple il faut
vraiment être optimale et je pense que
on continue à chercher effectivement là
la brique crue je pense qu'il va y avoir
un vrai enjeu sur le réemploi aussi
qu'on ne fait que commencer à traiter
vous parliez des bâtiments sans clim ni
chauffage c'est ou en france à sait pas
encore mais ça sera bientôt à lyon
d'accord quels sont les autres projets
sinon nexity qu'un texte ces paramètres
environnementaux et durable on a
effectivement la porte de montreuil j'en
ai dit un mot tout à l'heure le village
des athlètes qu'il a établi qu'avant les
jo dans le cas des jo qui va vraiment
être un mélange bois et puis béton bas
carbone et puis qui a cette
particularité très intéressante je pense
qu'il sera de plus en plus présentes
dans la ville de demain que c'est
réversible on va accueillir des athlètes
voilà on aura et quand les athlètes s'en
vont on va transformer ces bâtiments ou
font en appartement de taille diverse en
bureau en crèche les bâtiments
réversible quoi oui c'est ce qui se
passe en amont encore une fois ça se
passe en amont ça je pense
qu'effectivement il faut pas en porte de
montreuil sur certains immeubles on a
vraiment demandé aux architectes de nous
présenter une architecture des plans en
logements et des plans en bureau et au
fond on est capable d'aller de l'un à
l'autre et on a même garanti un coût de
transformation des logements en bureau
sis ou des bureaux en logements si le
destin venait à changer pour de montrer
donc c'est vraiment des choses qui sont
de plus en plus dans nos dans un mode de
fonctionnement et puis on a aussi je
pense une vraie incitations
d'aujourd'hui à travailler d'abord sur
la réhabilitation ça je pense que c'est
aussi une très grande transformation
être quatre cinq ans on avait quand même
le réflexe de dire bon finalement on va
construire un truc complètement neuve
qui correspond complètement à ce qu'on
veut aujourd'hui dans nos équipes il ya
vraiment le premier moment de se dire
mais qu'est ce qu'on peut faire avec ce
qui est déjà là et ça aussi c'est une
rupture est une vraie vraie révolution
dans nos modes de fonctionnement donc on
peut rêver en tout cas un logement des
bâtiments des immeubles des appartements
plus vert sans être plus cher j'insiste
elle part elle s'est faite on préfère à
part elle aussi comme avec les voitures
électriques qui aujourd'hui sont plus
chers que les voitures thermiques mais
qui à terme nous dit on quatre ans cinq
ans a du mal à dater seront au même rémy
les voitures électriques se faire de ma
page et c'est pareil mais bon ça peu
près 50% de plus et ces deux
technologies très très différente penser
ça que j'ai compris dans le logement je
pense qu'on va être en capacité de
revoir nos modes constructifs il faut
les alléger il faut les simplifier c'est
en les allégeant les simplifiant en
industrialisant qu'on finira par rendre
le logement abordable mais ça je pense
qu' il n'y a pas d'échappatoire il faut
vraiment que le logement vert soit un
logement abordable vous remercie
beaucoup tous cas merci d'arrêter avec
nous véronique b d'agde directrice
général de nexity merci à vous merci et
pour construire
[Musique]